it's not hard to see the generational
trauma indigenous communities suffer
from catholic residential school abuses
to broken families to children lost in
the cracks of foster care there is more
than one place to lay blame but it's the
young people who suffer most
they have
issues that they faced from their
parents like anger
alcohol abuse drug abuse
because of all the horrible things that
they went through
in residential school
and those unresolved issues are passed
down to the young people and they don't
know how to face it
both the canadian human rights tribunal
as well as federal courts recently ruled
that foster care survivors must be
compensated most will tell you that
there is no price tag big enough
how could somebody assess
forty thousand or fifty thousand or a
hundred thousand for being raped and
molested and condemned and belittled
and
robbed from family for no good reason
even though prime minister justin
trudeau's government has appealed court
decisions on compensation when pressed
he deflects
the millions of catholics
like me across this country expect the
church
to step up and fulfill its
moral responsibilities its legal and
economic responsibilities its historic
responsibilities but also
to practice what it quite literally
preaches
catholic bishops issued an apology last
month they are promising to fundraise
with a goal of collecting 30 million
dollars for victims over the next five
years but survivors say they simply
don't trust the church
memorials like these are across canada
honoring the 215 unmarked graves of
children in kamloops certainly there is
a role that has been played by the
canadian government as well as the
church in the generational trauma
suffered by indigenous peoples of canada
children taken from their families put
into an underfunded and often racist
foster care system whoever holds this
talking stick
now members of the community are trying
to bridge that divide
getting into the culture learning the
language learning the songs and the love
of the community
will replace that anger that's inside
them
even after a long road of struggle there
is hope and for some a feeling that it's
never too late to heal
took 199 years to learn we can't be
ruled by hatred in the enemy of our
peace a reclaiming of culture and faith
they say is the path to recovery jody
vance al jazeera vancouver